okay leader
okay thanks ian we will um we'll make a
start everybody
um with what is a special executive
meeting this evening to consider our
draft budget proposals
for um 2021 22.
um first item on the agenda is
attendances i'm not aware of any
apologies
um the second item is declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest from anybody at all
no okay thank you um
item three then is the exact strat for
revenue budget proposals for 2122 and
the medium term financial strategy
through to 2024 councillor ross
please thank you this afternoon i
introduced the executive's draft budget
proposals for 2122
and the medium term financial strategy
for 22.24
the key summary of figures for the
revenue budget based on current
estimates are
the over the draft overall budget
movement for 21.22 is an increase in the
net budget budget
from 175.52 million to 184.67 million
the budget gap for three years before
applying any of these draft budget
proposals is currently estimated to be
58.45 million
comprising 42.8 million of businesses
usual expenditure and funding pressures
and 15.65 million of covert 19 pressures
the report presents a set of proposals a
draft set of proposals to balance the
planned budget gap of 37.52 million in
2122
which in line with our three-year
strategy contribute towards closing this
budget gap
by 32.81 million via a mixture of
measures
which are additional funding plans you
severe march reserves
and new savings and income generation
these proposals will now form the basis
of consultation with members of staff
and where required the general public
and are therefore subject to change
the draft proposals are also subject to
review by the scrutiny committee
it should be noted that if all the
budget proposals in this report are
implemented there currently still
remains a residual budget gap of 17.95
million
comprising of 4.71 million in 2122
5.21 million in 2223 and
8.03 million in 2224.
we have to note that this assumes that
the ongoing impacts of covet 19
pressures are in 2122 only
any further recurrent impact in later
years will have to be assessed further
and this would represent a further
increase to the budget gap in those
later years
in respect of the kind of the council's
finances it's important to understand
the impact that covid19 has had
in february 2020 the council approved a
balanced budget for the year
but the onset of the pandemic has had
far-reaching and detrimental impact on
the council's expenditure
income from sales fees and charges and
funding from council tax and business
rates
income streams such as car parking
school catering registrar service
services licensing planning buildings
control have also been interrupted the
challenge for 21
20 20 sorry 2020 to 21 and 21 to 22
will be for the council to regain the
lost or deferred income
to avoid placing an additional burden on
the people and businesses of trafford
while at the same time attempting to
manage its finances effectively
the impact of the pandemic is monitored
and reported to the ministry of housing
communities and local government on a
monthly basis in the latest return sent
at the start of september
the projected impact on the council's
budget for this year
was an overall pressure of 45.6 million
a staggering position from having a
balanced budget just six months earlier
with that in mind it's fair to say that
planning local authority budgets have
never been
undertaken in such an uncertain period
and there are a range of unknowns which
will impact on the budget
this of course includes brexit at the
start of this at the end of this
calendar year
which brings with it many challenges for
trafford's economy
and a further impact assessment will be
commissioned in november once there is
more clarity on the likely resort of
trade negotiations with the eu
furthermore there is much uncertainty
about local authority budgets with 21
2122 and beyond
the government has signaled it will con
conduct a spending review in the autumn
which will set out funding envelope
for the local government in 2122 or
whether this will be
one year only it is it is not known
it is vital for the spending review
response to the enormous financial
strains placed on local authorities by
clovid19 and fully recognizes the total
fina financial impact
as well as indicating how the financial
sustainability of our social
services can be achieved
the local government provisional
settlement will then be announced in
december
and this will give us a more detailed
picture of the council's allocation and
available resources for next year
i said before the revised budget gap for
this year is for this 21 22 is 37.52
million
uh which includes 15.65 million of
direct pressures
estimated to continue from 2021 as a
result of covert 19.
given the developing nature of these
covert pressures the extent of which
we could become clearer as we move
through this um this current
financial year it is proposed that at
this stage to ring fence earmarked
reserves to cover them
the budget proposals allow us for
prudent repayment of reserves over the
longer term
although a few although future budget
positions allow
then this repayment should will be
reduced where possible
in respect of the budget gap created by
businesses usual pressures of 21.87
million
a range of savings proposals have been
identified as part of this report
the challenge we are facing is to
achieve a balanced budget for 2122 which
is an immense
challenge to say the least while this
involves some difficult
decisions our objective is to achieve a
balanced budget while still ensuring
that we keep our citizens safe
that we continue to deliver essential
services to the most vulnerable in our
community
and that we support our economy economy
and communities to build back better
i just wanted to spend a minute on the
um the delivery savings and reflect on
the delivery savings that we've had
since 2010.
since then the government has reduced
funding for local government as part of
its efforts to reduce the fiscal deficit
and this equates to about a 77 reduction
in per person grant funding for local
authorities
and has been the longest sustained
squeeze on public spending on record
alongside reductions in funding local
authorities have had to deal with a
growth in demand for key services
most notably adults and children social
care this demand is expected to continue
other pressures have been faced that
we'd be facing a higher national
insurance contributions
and inflationary pressure pressures on
goods and services the apprentice levy
and the national living wage
the cost of the council of recovery 19
pandemic is expected to be ongoing
and this has been obviously added into
our calculations for next year
and it's meant that by 2122 the total
value of
funding gap caused by expenditure
pressures pressures and
funding reductions since 2010 to 11
is about 217.73 million
there is a further forecast gap over the
next three years of 58.45 million which
of course
37.52 million relates to 21 22.
so you can see that over the past 10
years a significant amount of money has
been
stripped from local services which was
facing the biggest financial gap
that we have ever to face as a council
this next year
finally i'd like to thank nikki bishop
graham bentley and all the other
officers and colleagues involved in
getting our draft budget to this stage
and ask that the executive agree to the
recommendations set out on page two of
this report
thank you
thank you councillor ross are there any
questions or comments from members of
the executive
questions or comments more widely at
this point
i'll bring counselor evans in please
thanks thank you thank you council
weston um firstly can i start
by uh we had a briefing but from uh uh
nikki and graham last week can i just
commend their work it's
a gargantuan effort to get this to this
stage
and so commend them on that and the
whole of the team really um
well done and just a couple that that
and councillor ross hasn't alluded to
that are causing residence concerns
that have a pain the possibility is
selling off
and flexing house and the town hall
in altringham have caused uh quite some
consternation from residents
to be fair i i didn't know it was lease
or sell-off so
could have some clarification from
councillor ross on that and obviously on
the parking we
we would have uh we would have we've
been advocating for a while
um different choices and we will be
making different choices in that area
and would ask that given the pressure
that our businesses are continuing to be
on
that that could get some extra scrutiny
and just one more comment i
presume that the billion announced today
hasn't been factored into this in fact
see that it hasn't because it hasn't
changed over the past week
and i guess that's part of their
no e for the i in the recommendations
that it's going to be
a work in progress uh so if you could
just confirm that i'd appreciate that
thank you
[Music]
thanks councillor john's comment on um
the broad trust and then i'll bring
counselor right and if he wants to
make any contributions with regard to uh
well parking in particular yes of course
the thing to say at this point is that
this is the start of a conversation now
it's the start of a conversation with
residents
and it's going to go through the um
scrutiny process with uh
with the scrutiny committee as well so
so individual
points individual policies that are
within the um the document that we're
putting forward
will be subject to to further discussion
in in terms of the
um what you've referenced with regards
to the um
ultron town hall and flixton house
obviously there's a lot of discussions
that
can be had this isn't the first time
that we've looked at um looked at
proposals i could um
go back to um strep for public hall for
instance
um a few years ago there were proposals
there and the ultimately
that was taken over by the community
we're a long way off you know we're at
the very start of these discussions here
so
we'll see how those progress over the
next few months in terms of the money
that's been announced today
i'm not fully uh abreast of
of of what that money is for i think
it's for well my understanding was for
tier three
um areas but i i have to be honest with
you nathan i'm not too sure at the
moment but any additional funding that
does come in
over the next few months between now and
february will obviously be incorporated
into our um
into our final figures for a budget in
february
thanks councillor ross probably worth
noting just for um
clarity appreciating that we are uh
responding to
an ever-changing picture that we
anticipate although it is far too early
to say
um with any certainty um that there will
be
um perhaps up to three million more to
come to us on the back of um
announcements today but obviously um the
report
can't reflect what we didn't know um a
week ago and
you know we still have a long way to go
um with this
and that is obviously nowhere near where
we were hoping to get to in terms of
meeting the the impact of covered but
regardless
any additional support is welcome um
counselor right did you want to come in
at all
thanks leader yeah just in relation to
um ultragum town hall
and uh flixton house these are leases
not sales they're potential leases and
they're not they're neither are up for
sale i hopefully that will uh reassure
councillor evans
and just in relation to the parking
charges i'm afraid it's just a fact of
the
current budget situation and the budget
pressures that we're under that this is
something that we're having to bring in
um there have been difficult choices to
make i'm afraid
and um given the uh current situation
with parking starters in the borough
it is one decision that we are having to
make because
we have been unfortunately let down by
the government from a funding
perspective thank you later
thank you council right um councillor
coggins
as indicated and then councillor negro
thank you leader um yeah i wanted to
start um like others have done by by
thanking and acknowledging all the work
that uh nikki bishop and graham bentley
and
i'm sure council ross and all the team
have have done
um i think it's um incredibly
um difficult every year but um
particularly so this year um
and i think we have to acknowledge as
well how incredibly unhelpful it has
been to have
such um uncertainty from government and
and i know that the the budget team are
dealing with um a level of uncertainty
that is uh choose that word again on
unprecedented um
and to also acknowledge some of the
important uh decisions that are listed
especially in council russell's
introduction there and
supporting our care homes with ppe and
we're purchasing
spare capacity and all these things that
have had such a negative impact on our
budget it's really important to
acknowledge where that went
and and how they were important
decisions that that really
really helped and were really worthwhile
and and again to just thank the staff
again mentioned in cancer ross's
introduction whose lives have been
impacted with us by working from home
working more flexibly it's not always
more flexible if it's not what suits you
and wasn't your choice and to really
acknowledge all that
and there are various things to want to
um support in this
and building on the working from home
for the people that that works for and
and working more flexibly all sounds um
really really positive and forward
thinking and obviously you'll not be
surprised
to hear i'm pleased to see that the
climate action climate change action
plan is
is being taken um um
forward and i see there's a typo there
it does say that the anthesis report
came out in july
it was actually september and just to to
acknowledge that um
and also to welcome the poverty strategy
this upcoming and
and uh and of course i can see why the
the
increase in council tax discussed here
is inevitable in the circumstances
and i want to pick up on some of the
things that councillor um
evans had mentioned and obviously
altering him town hall cancer wright
says that this is for
lease not for sale that's not what it
says in the document i have
here i've just lost the page sorry um it
does say for sale or lease so that was
and that was top of my list of questions
and
will it be sale or at least because
those are hugely hugely different uh it
is in the appendix there it does
specifically say for sale or lease and
obviously if we sell
such an important heritage landmark such
as central focal point of the town
something that is an asset of community
value and it's been recognized as such
then it is gone to to the people of
walterham forever
and whereas if we lease it out obviously
there can be some short-term income to
the council
and whilst we retain ownership of the
building
and i was also slightly surprised that
as ward counselors we weren't consulted
at all
about this decision and the first we
heard about it was
uh i think as we saw it in the budget or
what they're about
so um just to to say that you know we
did think i suppose we were
surprised and it would have been um it
would have been good to be
to be consulted um
i can't go on i don't want to take up
too much time and
i suppose big question is is it missing
4 million and
and obviously there's little certainty
since it was published as to where that
will come from
and to again acknowledge the extreme
difficulty we're in
and some other worries are about adult
social care i see that obviously we're
moving to more reliance on technology
and i can see why that is financially
important
but there's this huge worry about
loneliness and that actually
adult social care is part of the way we
have our human interactions and how we
can
mitigate those problems while still
doing our financial problems
i i don't want to go on for too long so
i'll leave it there
[Music]
thank you um what i'll do with that with
that gel being there's quite a lot
in there um i'll ask firstly
uh council harding if she wants to
comment on the adult social care
elements um and then i'll bring
councillor ross in
um to clarify and then if there's any
other members of the exec can you just
raise your hand if anybody else wants to
come in on that please
uh council harvey uh thanks leader just
um thanks councillor cogging so
in relation to the um moving to more
assistive technology
that's always been part of our strategy
around adult social care
to enable people to live more
independently at home
of course i share with you the concerns
that technology does not replace
um human contact and i think we're all
acutely aware over this
pandemic just how much loneliness has
impacted on
lots of people's lives and particularly
those people that haven't been able to
see families
those that are residing in care homes so
as the documents suggest it's a
consultation but it's always been part
of the adult social care strategy
to look at new ways and means that we
can keep people at home for longer
and to enable them to live more
independently but of course as part of
the consultation you'll all be
able to have your say and it will go to
scrutiny too thank you
thank you council harding councillor
ross right thank you yes
i'll just cover um thank you very much
for your comments first of all uh
council coffins
coggins i'll um cover as many as i can
um first of all thank you for
um obviously reflecting on the way our
staff have worked over the uh
the past six months in particular and
how responsive they've been to the uh
the pandemic situation i don't think we
we do say enough how um how remarkable
the council shifted into um into what
was a
significant role dealing on the front
line with with the
with the pandemic um and i'm glad that
you welcome our our flexible
work proposals um and you know we we do
want to um to
to promote them as as as good as as much
as we can
in terms of ultrasound town hall i mean
it's it's it's very much
the executive view that it is it's
looking at the lease
and this is the start of the
conversation
so apologies if you you you're not happy
that um
we we haven't told you beforehand but
this is now the start of the
conversation
with ward councillors and with the
members of the old trinium
community as well as to you know how how
how we look at that as a as a
much cherished building which i i do
know it is in in the ultrasound area
um in terms of the four million it's
it's not uncommon
and it has been the case the past few
years that we haven't met
the budget at this point of time the
publication of the draft and we're going
to be working on the situation between
now and february to obviously
meet it which we have to do by law so
we we will look at that and come back in
february once we've gone through the uh
the consultations uh that that we have
and the discussions with uh with
scrutiny
and we'll come back with a balanced
budget to propose to council
at that point thank you
councillor ross i'm not seeing any other
indications from
from the exact and i think there was a
good range covered
there and with apologies to councillor
new gross um
i realized that nathan wanted to come
back in specifically on something erased
so i'll just bring him in now if that's
okay sorry nathan i missed that before i
brought councillor cockinson
i think councillor coggins has covered
it i was really just going to refer back
to
um councillor wright's comment that it
was for
lease and and and say i would relay that
back
to the residents that have contacted me
but in in the light of what
councilor ross has just said it does
seem
that what's in the document is what's in
the document and the position we are at
at this moment in time
and so both councillor ross and council
right are at different positions
on that i'm at to take councillor ross's
submission
at this point and then obviously not go
back to the residence
at this point thank you i mean i i have
to be
quite honest councillor evans that i
didn't really hear a divergence of views
from councillors and wright
um the position that i will say and this
is a
recorded um meeting as you are aware is
that we
favor very very strongly uh as an
executive looking at lease options not
disposal
um and that is obviously um
you know something that we have to
consider given the budget position that
we find ourselves in but
um you know clearly it is our intention
uh not to be selling these assets off
unless we absolutely absolutely have to
and the approach that we're looking for
is lease
uh councillor negros please thank you
can i
echo both previous question uh that
my thanks to nicki bishop and graham uh
bentley for walking me through
um my group through this budget um
and i've got to say how and i realize
that this isn't trafford's
position it's a national government lack
of funding but i am
absolutely shocked at some of these cuts
um they are
very regrettable as some of this
we hope will be avoided by um
further funding from the national stage
is it possible and i don't mean for
um council ross to answer this now but
could we have an indication of your
priority
should we find that
some or part of the gap
budget gap is met by government can we
have an indication what is most at risk
on your list of savings
as opposed to the least at risk so if
you
gained maybe i'll take a figure five
million extra
what would you keep and what is still at
risk
is that possible i'll let you speculate
on that counsellor councillor ross it's
a nice thought that there'll be five
million coming in so
yeah the the answer there
is that we're now starting the
discussion
with the residents of trafford and with
our colleagues on traffic counselling
scrutiny so
ultimately it it's not up to me to
decide what we do
with the uh with any additional money
and my goodness i hope that we get more
than five million from the government to
uh to bridge the gap and
and not have to um look at some of the
savings proposals that we currently
face but we have published this draft
set of proposals today we're now going
to go through a process and have
consultation where
where it is necessary and at the end of
that process
we will have a look at the feedback we
have we will also have a look at the
financial situation then
and then we'll make a decision when it
comes to the february budget
thanks councillor ross um okay so
we've heard from um three group leaders
i don't know if there were any other
members that were hoping to
um make a contribution if so it's
probably easiest if you just indicate in
the chat
that's okay clearly
um we are at an early stage with this so
maybe that people are waiting to see
what comes out
post consultation but council coping
wants to come back in
i'm just wondering if there's a gap and
later i would i would ping you a few
more extra questions if
if nobody else is um is
i didn't want to take up too much time
by all means counselor coggins
um
sorry just check just checking my notes
and the
changes to the bin collections are
obviously one of the things that is
going to cause biggest concern for
residents
and a suggested move to um to
fortnightly
um collections on the green bins and i'm
wondering what sort of approach we're
going to take to this are we going to
have
really constructive calms are we going
to be able to explain to residents
why we're doing this and really make
sure we get the information out without
at the same time
you know costing so much uh that the the
changes aren't worth
aren't worthwhile and there's also a few
things
um like dimming the lights i see uh is
on there
um by 20 street lights and i know some
councils for example have decided to
turn off street lights and maybe for a
few hours in the very depths of kind of
3 a.m to 5 a.m
and it's a way of saving money and
contrary to popular belief i don't think
there is evidence that
actually increases other problems and so
there may be an education
and and comes um issue issue there that
would be
um a way of achieving some of our carbon
reductions whilst also helping the
budget gap and wondering why the council
hasn't
hasn't gone for that and briefly just
if the friends group taking over park
maintenance again is one of the other
issues
that i can see is going to cause them a
lot of worries for residents and really
a lot of worries for our friends groups
who are often older
um people and and retired and and
you know really want to see their parks
doing well but don't necessarily have
endless time and energy to to give to
that
and so anyway a few more items i don't
want to take too much time but i thought
i'd pay a few more assume there's a gap
yeah thank you councillor coggins what i
will do
is i will ask councillor freeman if he
wants to comment on i think that i think
there was a reference to
a perceived impact on public safety uh
with the with the street light
uh position in particular so i'll ask
council agreement who wants to come in
on that
council patella she wants to come in on
the
um on the on the friends groups and
councillor absaid
on the um waste and recycling issues
before
asking councillor ross if there's
anything else that he wants to to
add um so i will start
um i think with uh councillor patel
please
thank you for that um the points on the
friends group so i have to say
i mean that that is acknowledged the
sort of
the role and the capabilities that
friends groups have
you know the role that they already play
which is amazing and we're really
grateful and thankful for that
um in the discussions at draft stage
this was always
to be something that would be voluntary
so
um we wouldn't expect friends groups to
take this on
across the board it would just be as and
where they felt capable
of doing it and i think it's probably
just a reflection of where we are
our financial position that we need to
look at options that
um that aren't particularly um
palatable but but we feel obliged to
explore them all
but yes we the friends groups have been
amazing especially over locked down
and yes we do acknowledge that that some
of them
may not be um have the capability to
take this sort of extra work on
uh thanks council patel councillor
freeman
yes thank you leader um the budget
proposals already already will
demonstrate that we do intend
to further dim street lighting in the
early hours
we also have a program that's involved
where we're going to look at the
street lighting we haven't yet converted
across the borough
to get that on to led so i think that we
are taking the steps
safety is a key thing and i've recently
dealt with the community
actually in hail who have had some
serious concerns about
lighting in their area and as a result
we've been able to find some money for
them to
to actually put street light some
lighting in a passageway so
i understand where uh council cognizance
is coming from but the actual switching
off of street lights
uh as suggested is certainly
not on our radar at this this time when
we've got the ability to further dim
them
which we will be doing thank you thanks
council agreement and i'll come to
councillor asset now um any any comments
particularly on the
waste and recycling side thank you
leader
i've gotten obviously that's been
outlined already but we are now at the
start of a process there
with public consultation over the next
few months now
obviously i agree with councillor
hawkins that should this proceed
that then of course comes would be
absolutely important
and it's something that will be looked
at and as this matter progresses
and of course we'll value yourselves and
any other members and indeed
residents feedback and actually on these
proposals so it's something that i
that uh obviously regret having to
consider but in the circumstances
it is really a it is really a horrendous
budget so we have to consider things
like this
and i think it is regrettable but
nevertheless i think it's something that
we are going to consult fully with
residents
and of course a proposal brought forward
following that consultation and members
will be able to comment on those
supports at that point
but we will be listening carefully to
everything that residents say in this
and these elected members before we drop
any final proposals on this
thank you leader thank you and
councillor ross is there anything you
just wanted to to say
um just just to wrap that up at all
don't worry i think my colleagues have
covered all the
um specific points that counselor
copying has raised um
obviously we're very keen to hear from
people now with suggestions um
unfortunately we are at the mercy of the
finances that we find ourselves
we would hope for a significant
investment from from government to help
bridge the
gap next year but if we don't get that
we will be having to consider
difficult decisions thank you
um i'll bring council miss blackburn in
please
thank you leader um the proposed savings
are determined partly by
voluntary severance what will happen
if there is a low take-up by existing
staff
and if they can post um a closed
what has the effects of the workload on
existing staff being evaluated
um councillor ross a really important
question one for
you and then if you feel the need um i
don't know if sarah salad's on the call
he may want to
take some of the technical elements of
that yeah i will um
thank you i will bring in sarah at this
point because
um i know that we are expecting an
update on on the scheme
um and the interest that has been shown
in it so far so i don't know if sarah is
on the call that could and could provide
a uh
an update to share um at this point in
time
i am on the call thank you councillor
awesome thank you and council mrs
blackburn
and the scheme has now been running for
three weeks and we have had a reasonable
uptake more than we expected and those
applications continue to come in and we
have extended the scheme due to the
pension cap regulations coming in last
week and allowing people to
um access pension figures in a timely
manner
and the scheme has been extended until
the 16th and we are reviewing our
position this week and we'll likely
extend that
and beyond that date and in answer to
your question around what next
well naturally we will have to to
consider that and consider that in
conjunction with our trade union
colleagues and
also um in conjunction with our heads of
service
and our staff forums to understand what
opportunities may be open to us
in terms of understanding the impact on
vacancy clearance
we do have a robust process in place and
the corporate director along with myself
and in some cases along with our and
finance director nikki bishop
will review those applications for
vacancy clearance
and in the main we are pushing through
as many vacancies as we can if it's a
critical uh to ensuring that we can
deliver safe and efficient services
across the council
thank you sarah but obviously um
the so so and that's in terms of the
specifics of
that scheme but clearly if it doesn't
realize in short the savings that we're
hoping
it will then it will increase the budget
gap uh further so we will have to look
at
other options um sadly um
i think also councillor jerome had
indicated
thank you leader yeah i've got two areas
where i just wanted to ask um
quick questions in july 2019
i got two um motions passed at council
the the first one was to do with um
wildflowers and
and leaving grassed areas unknown to
save on maintenance costs but creasy
biodiversity in the
in the borough too and i think there was
meant to be an audit and also
a consultation with residents which i'm
not sure has gone ahead
but this is an idea that would save
money and i see it is mentioned in the
in the budget so it'd be nice to know
more about that
and the the second motion that i passed
was on a similar scene
was about um planting more trees
throughout the borough
and again i'm not sure if this motion
has actually been taken forward
and an audit and a consultation has
taken place with residents
but i do see in the in the budget
proposals that city of trees
funding could be stopped um
so i'm wondering whether that will have
a detrimental effect on
on planting more trees throughout the
borough but also whether
the motion that i actually passed has
has been taken forward as well so um if
you could answer those questions that
would be great
thank you thanks dan what i will do is
um i will bring
councillor assad in um initially you'll
appreciate
damn that i haven't got the motions in
front of me so we may need to take away
and just have a look to check that we've
satisfied the requirements of those but
i will i am asked richard to come in as
well if he wants to clarify anything
beforehand but cancer i said is there
anything you'd like to
add on that thank you leader yes i mean
both these matters have been progressing
uh as you may know particularly uh there
was an item uh
on online today on the messenger website
but that you may have seen
if you get their day your dates you'll
see a press release in there
that indicates what we're doing with the
wild flowering uh meadows and so i'd
actually
ask you to look at that if he could
because all this will be contained
within the budget as well
in that sense if you want to look at
that uh article the messenger you should
be quite pleased by that
on the trees again yes this has been
progressing uh obviously we wouldn't be
uh
leaving cities before it had would have
a detrimental effect on the work there
and it's something obviously considered
as part of the overall budget we have
uh included a lot of trees over last
year i haven't got the figures with me
to say that but obviously you will have
seen you should have seen information
that's been come out of that
over the last few months and there's
been lots of tree planting in many areas
above
many of these were actually subjected to
uh press releases
indeed we've got a special some urban
tree planting schemes went ahead in many
areas of the brother
so they're actually all counting towards
our annual
numbers and that is being tallied up i
want to show you that we are looking at
significant increase in energy planting
although i have not got specific figures
to hand but i'm sure we can get that
information if that's helpful thank you
leader
okay thank you cancer i said what i'll
do i'll bring richard in
but i i mean we'll also undertake um
probably through richard and councillor
assad
to double check out the exact position
and provide those figures but richard is
there anything you wanted to
add i think councillor had said has
covered
most of it in terms of the additional
investment that we've put into tree
planting in the current year
and also the proposals that we have
taken forward around wildflower planting
but our budget proposals look to extend
that
more broadly during the next year but
we'll come back to as you said on the
specifics of the motions and the
response thank you
could you copy me in on that richard as
well because obviously for something
from council i just want to make sure
that
we follow that through um okay thank you
council jerome is there any
and think about stopping that and the
expenditure
that in my view is not well spent
um
thank you uh obviously we did publish it
during the summer the
the tree highway trees strategy so it
was there
and i think obviously i did send a copy
to council jerome as well so he has seen
that and
at the conclusion of the consultation
the report will be brought back to
executive on that
obviously it's a very complicated issue
and and obviously
so we don't go into the nitty-gritty
details of it tonight i'll show you that
once that consultation is complete a
report will be brought back to executive
on that thank you
thank you councillor um
okay i'm not seeing any further
indications
these are um although we're only at
draft stage
some fairly significant um
recommendations
for the executive to consider not least
um the proposals themselves but also
approval to proceed to consultation on
those elements of the draft budget that
require
it so um can i just ask members of the
executive and the final check that
nobody
is indicating no they're not okay um our
members of the executive hacking to
approve the recommendations please
all right thank you okay so they
are approved um and there is
no urgent business for the meeting so
that brings us to a close thank you
everyone for
your attendance and as councillor rox
did stress this is very much the start
of the process if there are particular
concerns that members have got
do get in touch with either councilor
ross or myself we will
do our best this is a really really
painful process and i actually do
want to acknowledge the the way in which
uh in particular the three group leaders
but all members who've spoken tonight
have
um recognized the challenge um and and
been very constructive in what they've
had to say
um and also placed on record um
not least because everybody else has
done it but it's important always to
remember
the work that our staff have done um in
these incredibly challenging times and i
know that the next um
the next year or two will be very very
challenging given the the budget
position so that is appreciated and
thank you
again for being so constructive but that
does bring us to a close
thank you all for your attendance thank
you